the inch closer to the holiday season
well many are wondering if they're
circling if they're still going to need
to wear the masks basically indoors for
any type of gathering now that all
depends of course on covet 19 cases and
the test positivity rate which of course
we all know has been falling it's been
on the decline so kate houston asked
governor sisilak if the indoor mass
guidance for vaccinated people could be
gone by the holidays
in order for the mask mandate to go away
the coven 19 test positivity rate must
be below 8 percent and the case rate
must be below 50 per 100 000 people over
two weeks while clark county is at 6.9
percent test positivity the case rate is
still around 115.3
governor sisselak says vaccines are the
solution to get rid of masks you're
protecting yourself your family and our
economy it keeps businesses open you see
here businesses are open because we've
got more people get vaccinated we need
to encourage everybody to get out and
get that vaccine so that we can continue
on the progress towards opening the
economy back up and creating more jobs
almost all of nevada including clark
county is labeled as a high transmission
area this week esmeralda and white pine
counties are listed as having low and
moderate risk of transmission kate
houston live local now
and as of today 55 percent of eligible
nevadans are fully vaccinated it's 54
percent for clark county